Let's come at this from the bottom up, in terms of the atomic elements out of
which connectors are built. The base element is called,
in the meta-paper, ducts, as in air-conditioning ducts. Okay? This,
this is the channel, has no associated behavior, with it.
It could, for example, be some kind of internet connection. Or
it could be all on one machine in terms of the underlying electronics.
It could be provided by the program language implementation, for
example in a virtual machine. It could be the operating system through some kind
of system call. Okay? Or it could be an inter machine communication, for
example with sockets. Ducts provide the mechanisms for transmitting the data,
and it could also be control information among the components.
Connectors go beyond ducts, by providing the protocol used by the ducts for
doing that communication. That is the sequence of interactions.
In addition to ducts, connectors may include internal mechanisms. For example,
some storage,uh, like, like would be used for buffers. Or computation,
computational elements such as might be involved if you,
if the, if the connector were fighting some kind of translation capability.